[Music]
good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight happy friday
it has been a turbulent week at times
pretty grim
but for once in this season of craziness
we have some good news
for you tonight and here it is 212 years
to the day
after abraham lincoln was born the
democratic party propaganda outlet that
stole his name
has finally collapsed lincoln's birthday
present
the end of the lincoln project we can
all celebrate that
there's probably never been an
organization sleazier
or more vicious in american politics
than the lincoln project
naturally it was funded heavily by the
tech oligarchs in silicon valley
the lincoln project set itself apart
from most political organizations
by never even addressing for the most
part ideas or policies instead they went
personal always immediately right for
the throat
rather than argue against what donald
trump might be doing or not doing
the lincoln project instead threatened
his attorneys and then spread filth
about his aides
in january for example one lincoln
project executive bragged that quote
we are constructing a database of trump
officials and staff that will detail
their roles in the trump administration
and track where they are
now they will be held accountable
it always sounded a little more like
ms-13 than a political operation
now because everything is irony there
are reports tonight that the fbi
is investigating the lincoln project
specifically one of its founders a man
called john weaver
weaver you may remember because he
helped manage john mccain's run for
president
he also worked for former ohio governor
john kasich he is a close associate of
bill crystal's
of course he is but in his spare time
john weaver spent enormous energy trying
to lure young boys into sex
at least one of those boys was 14 years
old 21 of john weaver's alleged victims
now accuse him of sexual harassment
it's an awful story but here's the worst
part of that story
the lincoln project clearly had a pretty
good idea what john weaver was up to
a lot of people did for decades
political consultants whispered rumors
that john weaver had tried to molest
little boys
karl rove to his credit once said that
out loud he was promptly attacked for
saying it by the atlantic magazine
the atlantic protected john weaver too
but it turned out to be apparently
accurate weaver's colleagues at the
lincoln project knew this but they hid
the truth from the public
and from law enforcement inside the
organization they made it clear
they understood what was happening we're
not guessing at this
here's an excerpt from a new piece in
new york magazine quote
beginning in september much of the
lincoln project staff convened in park
city utah where they hunkered down
in a coveted safe pod until election day
can't make this up by this time the
quote continues the allegations against
weaver were an
open secret in the company according to
former employees
one former employee said that's when his
boss warned him to avoid weaver
well when i was told it was almost in
passing that i did not want to be
involved with weaver specifically
because i am a young man the former
employee said
one night over drinks with much of the
staff four employees recall
weaver's behavior came up repeatedly as
a topic of discussion one person
remembers steve schmidt
and co-founder rick wilson telling
people weaver was quote
depraved and quote twisted and that they
wouldn't want to know the truth about
him
end quote so in other words inside the
office
lincoln project executives essentially
joked about john weaver soliciting sex
from teenagers
and as if the story couldn't get
creepier or more repulsive
we also learned this week that john
weaver once operated a children's
boutique
literally so the question is why are we
learning all of this now
well because the election is over donald
trump lost
so reporters no longer have political
motive to protect john weaver
until november the media had every
incentive to promote him as a man of
principle which they assiduously did
here's john weaver on 60 minutes john
weaver feels it's the party that's
betrayed him
i mean look leslie we've gone from
caring about
character rule of law defending the
constitution
a cogent national security policy free
trade
where all those issues imagine if
you travel the country for 30 years
fighting for republican principles and
you learn it was all a lie
oh so it's john weaver who was betrayed
it's really about character really it's
about principle the lincoln project
cared about democracy that's why they
did what they did it didn't have
anything to do with the money they got
nothing at all to do with money they'd
do it for free
they promised they would this subject
came up a lot and every time it did
lincoln project of money and that should
have told you something
here's lincoln project executive rick
wilson
and i'm going to quote their failed
strategists who are doing this for the
money
the easiest way in the world for a
republican strategist to make money
right now
is to shut up and say nice things about
donald trump so clearly we're in the
wrong line of work
clearly we're the long lot of work it's
all pretty funny of course that's the
opposite of the truth it always is
rick wilson found the only line of work
that would have him and apparently not a
moment too soon
published reports show that wilson faced
liens for hundreds of thousands of
dollars in unpaid federal taxes
oh speaking of character american
express took him to court for not paying
his credit card bills to the tune of
over 25 thousand dollars
so for a guy like that the lincoln
project was a godsend
and we can't overstate that according to
the associated press
quote of the 90 million dollars raised
by the lincoln project
more than half 50 million went to firms
controlled by the lincoln project's
executives
50 million dollars according to the
federal election commission the fec
in the month of december alone that was
before the georgia senate runoff
the lincoln project shoveled 1.5 million
dollars to steve schmidt who
incidentally bought a big new house
according to news reports
the lincoln project spent 38 thousand
dollars on a private jet company they
spent 1.7 million
with project co-founder mike madrid's
firm and they gave 420
000 to co-founder reed galen's firm hope
these guys saved the money because it's
hard to imagine we'll be hearing much of
the lincoln project
after today axios reported that steve
schmidt has just resigned
from the lincoln project he wrote a
resignation letter that's online tonight
that you should read
in it he portrays himself as the victim
it's all about him
and then says he's resigning because the
board of lincoln project
has too many middle-aged white men in
the name of diversity he must go
by the way lincoln project also saw
today the resignation of its spokesman
and a couple of other people
keep in mind just a week ago the lincoln
project was
powerful and feared and now it's done
it's over
it's not coming back the lesson is
things change fast
ask andrew cuomo how fast they change a
lot of people expected andrew cuomo to
be joe biden's attorney general maybe
the vice president of the united states
and for good reason cuomo played an
instrumental role in biden's campaign
for the white house
cuomo helped the uniparty leverage
coronavirus
for political ends he's one of the
reasons that a lot of voters in november
wound up believing that donald trump was
personally responsible for covid
some voters appeared convinced that
trump had cooked up the virus himself
in a lab deep beneath mar-a-lago joe
biden
knew that these propaganda points were
helping him
and he seemed grateful for andrew
cuomo's help
your governor of new york's done one
hell of a job he i think he's
he's sort of the gold standard i mean
look at the way you have governors like
cuomo who are out there
doing just keeping everybody informed
all day i think he's doing an
incredible job i think he has been the
lead horse here
i've talked to him frequently he's a
friend
i think he's doing a great job i really
mean it
andrew cuomo is the lead horse here he's
doing a great job
once again we don't fault joe biden for
saying untrue things he's just reading a
script
but in point of fact andrew cuomo was
not doing a quote great job
as governor of new york more people were
dying in his state than in any other
state in the country
but for most of the year nobody in the
media said that out loud
they allowed cuomo to win an emmy in
fact for saying things like this
my mother is not expendable and your
mother is not expendable
and our brothers and sisters are not
expendable
and we're not going to accept
a premise that human life
is disposable
human life is not disposable says the
abortion guy
well thanks to the new york post and a
handful of other relentless journalists
who pursued this story for more than a
year we now know that in fact andrew
cuomo does believe human life is
disposable of course we knew that
already
but here are the details andrew cuomo's
top 8 a woman called melissa derosa
privately admitted the truth in a call
with state lawmakers it's on tape
according to derosa the cuomo
administration deliberately covered up
the true number of chronovirus-related
nursing home deaths in the state of new
york
they refused to tell lawmakers how many
people were really dying
why did they do this why did they lie
well derosa explained why
the cuomo administration was worried
that telling the truth about how many
people were dying in nursing homes
would hurt joe biden and help donald
trump
quote he referring to donald trump
starts tweeting that we killed everyone
in nursing homes he starts going after
new jersey governor phil murphy
starts going after california governor
gavin newsom starts going after michigan
governor gretchen whitmer
then she worried trump directs the
department of justice to do an
investigation into us
and basically we froze dorothy continued
we were in a position where we weren't
sure if what we were going to give to
the department of justice or what we
gave to you guys
what we started saying was going to be
used against us well we weren't sure if
there was going to be an investigation
that played a very large role in this
in other words we lied because we didn't
want to get
caught the most basic explanation of all
we didn't want to help our political
enemies
there are now 15 000 confirmed and
presumed nursing home deaths in the
state of new york
that's up from 12 700 as recently as
late january
we don't have those figures because the
cuomo administration gave them
to us we have them because a few
reporters reporters like andrew kerr at
the daily caller
noticed that new york's death numbers
didn't count nursing home residents who
died of the chronovirus
at a hospital we know it because places
like the empire center think tank
obtained a
court order forcing cuomo to release the
data to the public which owns the data
he owns nothing he's a public servant
but he wouldn't give it up until forest
if we listen to the rest of the media we
wouldn't know any of this we'd only know
about his emmy
we would know anything about andrew
cuomo's order that forced nursing homes
to admit chronovirus positive patients
we'd be expected to believe his excuse
that all this was somehow donald trump's
fault
anyone who wants to ask why did the
state
do that with covert patients in nursing
home it's because the state
followed president trump's cdc
guidance who can we prosecute
for those deaths nobody
nobody mother nature
god and you had this political
conspiracy theory
that the deaths in nursing homes were
preventable
i think it is all politically motivated
if anybody looked at the facts
they would know that it was wholly
absurd
on its face it's funny how the
least competent least honest politicians
are also the most self-righteous if
anybody looked at the facts they would
know this is wholly absurd
on its face and of course it is wholly
absurd but not in the way cuomo meant it
joe biden is in the white house in part
because journalists
and members of both political parties
refused to look at the facts
and it's time we assess the facts
honestly